우리 VQE 알고리즘의 성공은
우리가 선택하는 상태와 circuit에
크게 달려 있어요.
저는 Victoria Lipinska이고, 이 영상에서는
그 선택지들을 살펴볼 거예요.
어떤 옵션들이 있는지 알아봐요.
VQE의 양자 파트를 실행할 때마다
등장하는
모든 요소들을 자세히
살펴볼게요.
먼저 레퍼런스 상태, 즉
초기 상태라고도 부르는 것부터 시작해요.
레퍼런스 상태를 파라미터화된
circuit에 통과시키는데, 이걸
variational form이라고 해요.
처음엔 파라미터 초기값을 사용하고,
그 다음 circuit을 통과한 상태를
Hamiltonian 기저에서 측정해서
기댓값을 구해요. 이제
각 요소를 하나씩 살펴볼게요.
레퍼런스 상태부터 시작해요.
레퍼런스 상태의 일반적인 선택은
영(zero) 상태예요.
그게 바로 양자 컴퓨터가
이미 초기화된 상태거든요.
양자 화학 문제의 경우에는,
소위 Hartree-Fock 상태를
사용할 수도 있어요.
이건 Hartree-Fock 방법의
결과물이에요.
간단히 말하면, Hartree-Fock 이론은
레퍼런스 상태를 구성하는
간단한 방법을 제공해요. 양자 시스템의
바닥 상태를 근사하는 방식으로요.
상태 공간 내에서의 회전을 찾아서
바닥 상태 에너지를 최소화해요.
마지막으로, 레퍼런스 상태는
문제에 따라 매우 특수할 수 있어서,
커스텀 상태를 선택하고
싶을 수도 있어요.
시스템의 특성을 알고 있을 때, 예를 들어
대칭성이나
상태 내 전자의 특정 개수를 알면,
그걸 활용해서
VQE 알고리즘의 수렴을
더 잘 이끌 수 있어요.
좋은 레퍼런스 상태를 고르는 건
수렴에 중요해요.
바닥 상태에 가까운
레퍼런스 상태는
문제를 훨씬 더 쉽고 빠르게
수렴시킬 수 있어요.
마찬가지로 중요한 건
variational form에 넣어주는
초기 파라미터 값의 선택이에요.
따라서 레퍼런스 상태와
초기 파라미터에 따라,
빠르게 수렴할 수도, 느리게 수렴할 수도,
아니면 아예 수렴하지 않을 수도 있어요.
이 그래프를 보면서, 시각화를 위해
파라미터 공간에 파라미터가
딱 하나만 있다고 상상해봐요.
아주 좋은 레퍼런스 상태를 사용하면
최종 바닥 상태에 매우 가까운 곳에서
시작할 수 있어서
수렴이 빠르게 돼요.
반대로, 바닥 상태에서 아주 멀리,
예를 들어 여기에서 시작하면,
레퍼런스 상태 a처럼,
높은 에너지 장벽을 넘어야 해서
수렴이 매우 느려지거나
아예 안 될 수 있어요.
이 부분은 이 코스의
고전적 최적화 모듈에서
더 깊이 다룰 거예요.
이제 레퍼런스 상태에 작용하는
파라미터 circuit을, 즉
variational form을 살펴볼게요.
이 circuit, 즉 theta에 대한 U가
레퍼런스에 작용하면
시험 상태라고 부르는 걸
만들어내요.
theta의 psi, 또는 ansatz라고도 해요.
이 ansatz 상태가 적절한 기저에서
측정되어
에너지에 대한 기댓값을
얻게 돼요.
여기서 다루는
variational form들은
화학에서 영감을 받은 거예요.
하지만 양자 머신러닝에서
영감을 받은 것들도 있다는 걸
기억해 두세요. 그리고 다른
근미래 알고리즘들, 예를 들면
양자 근사 최적화 알고리즘
같은 것들도 있어요.
화학 ansatz의 일반적인 선택지를
몇 가지 살펴볼게요.
Unitary coupled cluster, 즉 UCC는
최초의 VQE 논문에서
처음 제안된 방법이고,
양자 화학 문제에서
흔히 사용돼요.
보통 양자 상태를 파라미터화할 때,
지수적으로 많은 파라미터를
다루게 돼요.
그런데 준비 circuit을 효율적으로
만들려면,
다항식 수의 연산이
필요하고
따라서 다항식 수의
파라미터가 필요해요.
UCC는 그런 circuit으로
시험 상태를 준비하는 방법의 예시인데,
coupled cluster 방법에서
유래했어요.
그게 바로 양자 화학에서의
황금 표준이거든요.
가장 일반적인 선택은
unitary coupled cluster
singles and doubles ansatz,
줄여서 UCCSD예요.
UCCSD는 문제의 특정 전자 배열에서
동기를 받기 때문에,
시스템을 제대로 반영하는
레퍼런스 상태가 필요해요.
그게 바로 Hartree-Fock 상태예요.
UCCSD ansatz는 보통 바닥 상태를
잘 근사해요.
주어진 분자에서 단일 및 이중
전자 여기를 잡아내기 때문이에요.
UCCSD의 파라미터 수는
스핀 궤도함수 수의
제곱에 비례해서 늘어나요.
UCCSD는 문제에 맞게
잘 조정할 수 있지만,
안타깝게도 제곱 스케일링은
여전히 매우 깊은 circuit으로 이어지고,
그게 현재 양자 컴퓨터에는
어려운 부분이에요.
그래서 IBM 연구자들이 더 휴리스틱한
접근법을 제안했어요.
variational form을 하드웨어에
맞게 조정할 수 있는 방법인데,
효율적으로 실행 가능한
circuit을 만들어줘요.
즉, 시험 상태가 quantum gate들로
파라미터화되고,
실제 물리 장치에
맞게 적응돼요.
이건 하드웨어 친화적인
매우 휴리스틱한 접근법이에요.
이 예시들을 바탕으로,
variational form을 표현하는 데
우리가 가진 가능성의
스펙트럼을 살펴볼게요.
이것들 중 많은 부분이
이미 Qiskit에 구현되어 있어요.
그러니 직접 시도해 보길 권해요.
어떤 게 풀고자 하는 문제에
가장 적합한지 알아보세요.
그래프를 보면, 한쪽에는
매우 휴리스틱한
variational form들이 있어요.
문제 특수성은 낮지만,
실제 하드웨어에서 구현되도록
설계된 것들이에요.
또한 높은 표현력을 가지고 있어요.
다시 말해
이것들로 많은 양자 상태를
표현할 수 있다는 의미예요.
하지만 나중에 고전적 최적화
단계에서 문제가 생길 수 있어요.
바로 고전적 최적화 과정에서
맞닥뜨리는
소위 barren plateau 문제인데,
다음 모듈에서 다룰 거예요.
반대편에는 문제 특수성이
높은 unitary
coupled cluster가 있어요. 고전 화학에서는
뛰어난 성능을 보이지만,
circuit 깊이가 너무 깊어서
양자 하드웨어에서 구현하기 어려워요.
일반적으로 계산이 더 잘 되려면
몇 가지가 필요해요.
우선, 레퍼런스 상태와
초기 파라미터 집합을
바닥 상태에 가까운 ansatz 상태를
만들도록 선택해야 해요.
그리고 둘째, 불필요한 파라미터는
피해야 해요.
불필요한 파라미터는 아무 이득 없이
circuit 깊이만 늘리거나,
더 큰 파라미터 공간을
만들어서
고전적 최적화에서
plateau로 이어질 수 있어요.
어떤 파라미터가 필요한지는
문제에 따라 다르고,
신중하게 생각해야 하는
문제예요.
이제 오늘의 주인공인
Hamiltonian이 이 모든 것 속에서
어디에 숨어있는지 얘기해볼게요.
이전 섹션에서 배운 것처럼,
qubit 매핑 후 Hamiltonian은
가중치가 붙은 Pauli 연산자
문자열의 합으로 표현돼요.
결국 우리가 하고 싶은 건
variational form이 만들어낸
ansatz 상태에서 Hamiltonian의
기댓값을 구하는 거예요.
다행히도 양자 역학은
선형적이어서,
그 성질을 이용해서
기댓값을 구할 거예요.
작동 방식은 이래요.
Hamiltonian은 Pauli 연산자의
가중합인데,
선형성 덕분에
합의 기댓값은
각 Pauli 문자열의 기댓값의
합과 같아요.
이게 좋은 이유는, 이미 알고 있듯이
Pauli 기저에서 측정하는 건
표준 측정 기저를 회전시키는 것만큼
간단하거든요.
합으로 표현된 이 거대한 Hamiltonian에서
바로 기댓값을 측정하는 대신,
각 항의 기댓값을 먼저 구하고
마지막에 해당 가중치를 곱해서
합산해요.
그래서 많은 자료들에서
ansatz 뒤에 single qubit 회전만
있는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
이게 바로 circuit을 실행할 때마다
Hamiltonian을 구현하는 방식이에요.
다음 영상에서는,
고전적 최적화 단계에서
무슨 일이 일어나는지 살펴볼 거예요.
거기서 만나요.